hey guys it's vadim with max tech and
welcome to our 2021 apple watch buyer's
guide where i have the brand new apple
watch series 7 as well as the series 3
and the apple watch se so in this video
i'm going to show you guys all of the
differences and compare them so you guys
will know which one you should buy so
starting off with the prices we have the
series 3 for 199 dollars we have the se
for 279 and of course the series 7 for
399
and that is double the price of the
series 3. it's a lot more expensive so
basically in this video we're going to
see if it's worth spending twice the
cash on the series 7. now the first
difference i want to get into is the
actual cases themselves now both the
series three and the se can only be
purchased right now with an aluminum
case you have either space gray or
silver on the series three you have also
gold like we have here on the se
but the series 7 can also have a variety
of aluminum case colors like this green
brand new one that we have as well as
the red and the blue and you also have
the options for the stainless steel and
the titanium which are a lot more
premium and comparing the cases
themselves there are some differences
looking over on this left side the
series 3 has the oldest layout for the
microphone and the speaker as you can
see we have the speaker right there with
the microphones now on the newer ones
like the se and the series seven the mic
goes to the other side so there's kind
of like less interference and we have a
newer design for the speaker for the sc
and another newer design that's brand
new for this series seven and now as i'm
holding these up you can see the mics on
both the se and the series 7 but there
are some other differences first of all
for the crown you actually get the kind
of notches all the way through the crown
instead of just on the edge and the se
and the series seven actually have
haptic feedback so you can kind of feel
some uh pressure or some like the haptic
motor whereas you don't feel anything on
the series three and the last difference
is that the side button actually sticks
out on the series 3 whereas it's flush
on both the se and the 7. now one thing
i do want to mention is that all three
of these apple watches were the largest
size at the time so the series 3 is a 42
millimeter the se is a 44 and the new
series 7 is a 45 so it actually gets
slightly taller than the old ones and
the final difference i want to mention
before we go to the back sides is that
the case is more rounded not more flat
it's more rounded this year so it kind
of like meets with the glass
so we'll definitely show you guys the
display differences in just a minute all
right now that we're on the backside
there are some big differences here the
series 3 has a composite back so it's
basically plastic and i don't know if
you can tell but it's got a lot of like
micro scratches on it now the se has a
new sapphire glass and ceramic back just
like the series 7 so they're more
scratch resistant and they look much
nicer now you'll also notice some
differences in the layout of the sensors
so the series 3 has the first gen
optical heart sensor then we have the
second gen and then finally the third
gen so it's basically going to be better
at sensing all your heart rate data and
everything like that and the series 7
also supports the new blood oxygen
monitoring feature and the nice thing is
that even the series 3 gets the high and
low heart rate notifications as well as
the irregular heart rhythm notifications
but the se and the series 7 come with
extra features like international
emergency calling fall detection noise
monitoring a compass an always-on
altimeter and an option of buying a new
model with cellular service and now that
we're done with the backs i've got them
all right here on my wrist it's
definitely not comfortable but i do want
to show off one more feature that's
exclusive to the series seven and that's
the ecg feature as you can see i have my
finger on the crown and it's making an
electrical signal and it's basically
just measuring my heartbeat so let's let
this run and there you go it's finished
it just confirmed that i am i guess kind
of healthy but
moving on there are some massive
differences in the displays and i know
you can't really see that right now
because they're all black but there are
some massive differences that i'm going
to show you really soon but first i want
to get over some of those other
technical differences in terms of the
chips or the processors that are
powering these apple watches the series
3 gets a very old s3 chip and to be
honest it isn't as smooth of an
experience in terms of the performance
now the se has the s5 chip from the
series 5 apple watch and there are
literally no i guess disadvantages or
noticeable performance issues it's
definitely fast enough and now the
series 7 has the s7 chip which is
actually a rebranded s6 because both the
series 6 and the 7 are 20 faster than
the s e so no performance issues it's
definitely really nice and fast now in
terms of the wireless specs both the se
and the series 7 have the new w3
wireless chip which basically makes the
connection between your iphone and your
apple watch it makes everything work
really nicely with low latency while the
series 3 actually has the older w2 chip
now the series 7 exclusively has the u1
ultra wideband chip which is meant for
tracking and being as accurate as
possible now moving on both the se and
the series seven have a new second
generation speaker that is fifty percent
louder than the one on the series three
so let's just do a nice little speaker
test it's currently cloudy and 57
degrees it's currently cloudy and 57
degrees it's currently cloudy and 57
degrees now there's also another sensor
difference both the se and the series 7
have a new 32 g-force accelerometer
which enables the fall detection feature
while the series 3 only supports up to
16 g's so it doesn't have it and in
terms of the storage there's actually a
massive difference the series 3 only has
8 gigabytes of storage for storing
things like music or whatever else while
both the sc and the series 7 have 32
gigs which is definitely nice and now
before we get into comparing the
displays the se and the series 7 support
bluetooth 5 while the series 3 only
supports bluetooth 4.2 but the series 7
exclusively supports the 5 gigahertz
wi-fi band so you're having faster wi-fi
speeds and it also supports faster
charging that's 33
faster using the new usbc charging cable
and here we go the biggest difference
that you are gonna notice day to day we
have the display differences 42
millimeter then we have 44 and 45 and
even here you can actually see a
difference you can see how limited this
display is compared to much better and
bigger here and way bigger like very
small bezels here and check this out
boom always on display which is
exclusive to the series 7 and the other
high-end older watches but as you can
see this is definitely more premium
because you can see the time you can see
the date you don't have to tap it or
raise your wrist to turn these on and
now finally we can examine the display
differences as you can see we have a
totally square display on the series 3
and in my opinion this looks like
garbage i hate it i can't stand it
because we have the rounded edges or the
corners on the other watches so as you
can see you have thinner bezels here
with the rounded corners looks much
better on the se but on that series 7
wow those bezels are incredibly thin and
you're getting just so much more display
than on the other ones
and i wasn't expecting this to be as
nice but man it's definitely more
immersive and it looks much better as
you can see here i have the maps app
open and it's just so much more
immersive with the new one and it's very
quick and snappy whereas you have like
this old
square design like you can barely see
anything on the series three it's
definitely limiting now between the sc
and the series seven it's not that big
of a difference but just having those
super thin bezels
definitely nice now what's awesome about
the larger display on the series seven
is that you actually get a full-size
keyboard where you can tap or you can
swipe to make different text messages
compared to the series 3 where you have
to type everything out letter by letter
just like on the se
so that definitely sucks compared to
having the full sized keyboard
exclusively on the series 7. and overall
the series 7 is more useful because it
has much newer watch faces that look
better than the ones on the older ones
especially if you take a look at the
modular duo where you have two
full-sized complications which you can't
get on any other apple watch and now the
last thing i want to mention before we
get into the buyer's guide portion of
this video is battery life even though
apple rates all of the apple watches at
18 hours of battery life the series 3
actually gets noticeably worse battery
life than the se and the series 7. now
since the sc does not have an always on
display it actually might get better
battery life than the series 7 because
this has to stay on and it is brighter
than it was before and now let's get
into the buyer's guide starting off with
who should be buying these series 3. to
be completely honest i don't think that
anybody should be buying the series 3
because first of all it's only 80
dollars cheaper than the se and it has
so many disadvantages especially the
performance with the s3 chip where you
do in real life notice a lot of
stuttering and choppiness and stuff just
loading slowly compared to the se and
the other apple watches and on top of
that the display is just so much worse
and the speakers the crown just
everything's just not a good experience
and honestly i don't think apple should
be selling it anymore it's just so
outdated now moving on to the se this is
actually a really great choice because
you can set this up if you buy the
cellular model for a kid and they can
use just the apple watch by itself
without having to connect it to an
iphone and it just overall has a nice
feature set almost matching the same
features from the series 5 so it's
definitely a good value for 279 and i
think if you don't really care that much
about having the highest end or best
features you just want a nice and new
fresh apple watch the se is definitely a
great choice and finally we have the
series 7. this is for people who haven't
upgraded for years maybe you still have
the series 3 or maybe the series 4 and
you're finally ready to upgrade this is
a nice upgrade because it has all the
latest features the health features with
the blood oxygen monitoring and
everything else and of course the larger
display with the much slimmer bezels
it's just a nice immersive experience
that lets you use the apple watch to
basically the max and to be completely
honest just the always on display by
itself just makes it feel so much more
useful and premium because the display
is on and it kind of looks like a real
watch where you actually have stuff
there instead of being completely black
and it honestly just looks weird to have
nothing there while the always on
display is there and it looks nice and
it's useful you can read all your text
whatever you have your information and
the time it's just so much better now
finishing off with my own personal
experience with which one you should buy
if you're a new apple watch buyer i'd
say just go straight for the series 7
for 400
because in reality most people keep
their apple watches much longer than
their iphones so we're talking four to
five years with the same apple watch so
for a hundred and twenty dollars more
than the se you're just getting so much
bang for the buck so it's not that much
more money if you're considering 45
years of using it so definitely just buy
this one if you're a new apple watch
buyer so there you guys go hopefully
this video helps you make a decision on
which apple watch to buy and we're
actually gonna have the links to each of
these apple watches including the series
four five and six at a discount with the
sales on amazon down in the description
below so if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]